Michelle, did you say something?
I want my crib.
Michelle, cribs are for babies.
You're a big girl now.
See, the trick to a new bed is you gotta break it in, you know?
You gotta get the feel of it.
Alright! First, let's check the shocks, okay?
Here we go.
Ready?
That baby's got a good ride, doesn't it?
Okay. And next and most importantly, you gotta find the sweet spot.
Now, the sweet spot is the place that makes you feel all nice and cozy and cuddly.
Get out. Let me find it.
Okay. Alright. Let me see. Let me see.
That's it. I found it. Okay. You ready?
Come on. Let's see if you can get it.
Here we go. Ready? There we go.
There. You're right in the sweet spot.
Ah, you're gonna sleep like a baby, I mean, like a big girl.
Good night, little ankle-biter.